cabinet met this morning to assess the
up-to-date
covert situation which i must say at the
outset
is extremely serious and to discuss what
further action
is necessary to minimise further spread
of the virus i will set out
the decisions we reached shortly however
i can
confirm now in summary that we have
decided to introduce
from midnight to night for the duration
of january
a legal requirement to stay at home
except for essential purposes
this is similar to the lockdown of march
last year
however before i set out these decisions
in more detail i want to take
the opportunity to explain in some
detail
why they are so necessary in the past
few weeks there have been
two significant game changers in our
fights against this virus
one the approval of vaccines is hugely
positive
and it does offer us the way out of this
pandemic
but the other the new faster spreading
variant of the virus
is a massive blow and possibly the most
simple
way of explaining the challenge we face
right now is to compare it
to a race in one lane we have vaccines
and our job is to make sure they can run
as fast as possible
and that's why the government will be
doing everything we can to vaccinate
people as quickly
as possible and i will say more about
that later
but in the other lane is the virus which
as a result
of this new variant has just learned to
run much faster
and has most definitely picked up pace
in the past couple of weeks
to ensure that the vaccine wins this
race it is essential to speed up
vaccination
as far as possible but to give it the
time it needs to get ahead
we must also slow the virus down and
because it is now spreading faster
that means even tougher restrictions are
necessary
the evidence presenting officer is now
compelling
that the new variant is up to 70 more
transmissible than previously
circulating strains
and that it may add as much as 0.7
to the r number and according to recent
analysis
of pcr test samples it appears that the
new variant already accounts for almost
half of all new cases and faster spread
is undoubtedly driving the very serious
situation we now face today's case
numbers
uh 1 905 new cases with 15 percent of
tests
being positive illustrate the severity
and the
urgency of the situation no new deaths
were reported
today but that is because yesterday was
a sunday and registration offices were
largely closed
but since i updated parliament before
christmas 289 deaths have been recorded
in our daily figures
that again reminds us of the continuing
grief that this pandemic is causing
but let me stress this is not just about
one single day's numbers
we are now seeing a steeply rising trend
of infections
indeed it is no exaggeration to say that
i am more concerned about the situation
we face now
than i have been at any time since march
last year
in the week from the 23rd to the 30th of
december
the day incidence of cases per hundred
thousand
of the population increased by 65
percent
from 136 per hundred thousand to 225
per hundred thousand test positivity has
risen sharply too
the next update on the numbers of
covered patients in hospital
and intensive care will be published
tomorrow i would expect these to show
that
nationally the total number of covered
patients in hospital
is now close to the april peak and in
some boards
the pressure is already very real for
example in terms of hospital beds nhs
airshed and iron is currently at 96
of its covert capacity and three other
health boards borders greater glasgow
and clyde and lannister
are above 60 of their capacity
the number of people in intensive care
is still significantly lower than the
april peak which of course partly
reflects the fact that treatment of
covid
has improved significantly since last
spring
but even so the total number of patients
in intensive care
in scotland is already above normal
winter levels indeed all mainland health
boards have now exceeded their normal
intensive care unit capacity and it is
important to be clear and this is a key
point
the people who are in hospital and
intensive care now
are likely to have been infected 10 days
to two weeks ago
that means that these numbers reflect
what the level of new cases was
around two weeks ago and given that the
number of cases has increased
significantly since then that means we
can expect to see significantly
increased pressure
on the nhs over the course of this month
now contingency plans remain in place to
double and then treble icu capacity if
necessary
and the nhs louisa jordan continues to
be available to help
meet demand as indeed it has been doing
in recent months
12 thousand patients have attended there
for scans and outpatient appointments
nearly
five thousand nhs staff and students
have been trained there
and it is currently being used for
covered vaccinations
in short nhs services are coping at
present although the pressure on
frontline staff
is considerable but already in some
areas the position is fragile and it is
getting more challenging
and if the rate of increase in case
numbers that we have seen
in the past two weeks was to continue
unchecked there would be a real risk of
our nhs being overwhelmed
even with contingency plans in place in
fact our modeling suggests that without
further intervention
we could reach inpatient covert capacity
within three or four weeks